foreign
[Music]
the Barbie movie about the famous
plastic doll has already achieved a
phenomenal success at the global box
office after only 17 days and is
currently the second most successful
movie of the year it's a unique success
story Barbie has been in theaters for a
mere three weeks and it already stands a
good chance of becoming the most watched
movie of the year the story of Barbie
and Ken recently surpassed the billion
dollar Mark with its box office takings
making it a hit that surely no one would
have anticipated when a Barbie movie
adaptation was first announced the
reasons for this huge success are
probably many in Buried on the one hand
it is an absolute favorite among critics
and viewers scoring 89 on Rotten
Tomatoes and a critics average of 80 on
Metascore on the other hand the success
is probably also thanks to the superb
marketing campaign anyone who is
regularly on social media is unlikely to
have missed the hashtag barberheimer
during the shooting of the film photos
from the set were also published over
and over again showing Robbie and Ryan
Gosling in brightly colored outfits
hanging out in Venice Beach for example
this led to a number of collaborations
with Brands such as Airbnb Google Crocs
and Tick Tock if one combines these
versatile aspects with one another it
includes the word of mouth advertising
Factor the result became a campaign that
was almost impossible to resist but the
success includes another special aspect
Greta Gerwig goes down in Hollywood
history as the most successful female
director of all time thus displacing the
previous title holder and Wonder Woman
director Patty Jenkins meanwhile the
other part of the barberheimer
phenomenon Christopher Nolan's
Oppenheimer has to be content with a box
office result of currently 560 million
dollars that surely is an impressive
figure too but the winner of the box
office duel between the two unequal
films should be clear the challenge now
is to knock the Super Mario Brothers
movie off its title as the most
successful film of the year the animated
film about the famous plumber was able
to bring in more than 1.3 three billion
dollars worldwide and is thereby
relatively close to Barbie so it may
only be a matter of time before more
records are broken
[Music]
foreign